une robe sur sensation
bonjour et bienvenue sur Radio sensation
en association avec TV 78000 émission
enregistré au Parlement européen de
Strasbourg voici le sommaire de ce
nouveau numéro la construction
européenne et ses personnages
emblématiques vous parleront cette
semaine de Simone Veil elle a été la
première femme présidente du Parlement
européen je recevrai l'eurodéputé
Laurence parents l'occasion d'évoquer
2022 année européenne de la zone voyager
dans l'assiette vous découvrirez un plat
typiquement britannique le fixe aussi
les superstitions en Europe Évelyne
Keller auteur du livre 300.000
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire quelles sont
les croyances autour du sel parce que
nous verrons à la fin de cette émission
mais avant que fait l'Europe dans notre
région un exemple tout de suite
zone Europe l'Europe dans ma région
aujourd'hui je suis exilé commune
environ une heure de Paris on est plus
précisément au panier de la ferme ça
c'est une boutique qui travaille
essentiellement avec des producteurs
locaux et la petite particularité c'est
qu'elle a bénéficié à plusieurs reprises
des européennes pour plusieurs projets
on a rendez-vous avec Philippe pour en
parler
[Musique]
oui je m'appelle Philippe moi je suis
arrivé donc je suis je suis plutôt
agriculteur en grandes cultures
et je me suis diversifier en regroupant
la production locale alors la carte
c'est nos producteurs donc vous voyez
que sur la carte principale donc c'est
tous les producteurs qui sont a moins de
30 km de la ferme donc c'est
principalement tous nos producteurs dans
un premier temps je voulais mettre en
place des paniers de produits locaux qui
distribuer aux clients ce projet juste
ont été financé à 50 % par les fonds
européens
constitué de tout ce qui était site
internet j'ai investi 10000 € au départ
et et j'ai touché 50 % de subvention
[Musique]
coucou on est la boutique est juste en
dessous
et verser cette voiture là qui était
fortement abîmé et du coup on a mis des
panneaux photovoltaïques donc
l'investissement se lève à peu près à
160000 €
et j'ai touché 25 % de subvention la
moitié par l'Europe et la moitié par la
Région Île-de-France
le corps de ferme est quand même assez
grand et demande beaucoup de frais là on
m'a proposé dans une grange qui
commençait à être à l'abandon et qui se
dépêcher c'est fortement de faire des
logements étudiants donc je vous ai rien
dit
donc là on est devant l'ancienne grange
qui est à l'abandon qui est devenu
maintenant des logements étudiants les
jeunes qui sont là ce sont des étudiants
ou des premières emploi on va dire c'est
que des meublé et les loyers sont
environ 25 % inférieur au loyer que l'on
trouve dans le secteur en équipe avec
cette 3e éd européenne Philippe donc
mets ton placer 6 logements étudiants le
coût total de ce projet se lever à
367000 € donc 28 % a été financé par des
fonds européens
[Musique]
zone Europe
comme chaque semaine nous vous faisons
découvrir celles et ceux qui ont
participé à la construction européenne
aujourd'hui Simone Veil elle a été la
première femme présidente du Parlement
européen son parcours avec Europe direct
et la maison de l'Europe
de son nom de jeune fille
Jacob est né le 13
elle est déporté en mars 1944 alors
qu'elle n'a que 16 ans elle vit pendant
13 mois les atrocités de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et les camps de
concentration
malgré ces épreuves Simone Veil reprend
ses études de droit et entre dans la
magistrature en 1957 en 1970 elle est la
première femme occupé le poste de
secrétaire général du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature après avoir été aux
fonctionnaires de l'administration
pénitentiaire du ministère de la Justice
son expérience et prise de position la
même d'être nommé ministre de la Santé
sous Valéry Giscard d'Estaing est dans
le gouvernement de Chirac en
1974 elle propose au Parlement un projet
de loi pour dépénaliser l'avortement
c'est prise de position sur le sujet
sont devenues célèbres nées en janvier
1975 l'avortement est légalisé en France
en 1979 elle participe aux premières
élections européennes sur la liste de
l'Union pour la démocratie française
elle est élu membres du Parlement
européen et allons devient la présidente
est la première femme occupé ce poste
son élections au Parlement européen est
un symbole fort symbole de la
réconciliation franco-allemande
Simone Veil considère le projet européen
comme un moyen de maintenir la paix et
de tourner la page des guerres mondiales
lors de son discours d'investiture à la
présidence du Parlement européen elle
est non c'est 3 ambition pour l'Europe
pour relever les défis auxquels l'Europe
est confronté c'est dans trois
directions qu'il nous faudra l'orienter
l'Europe de la solidarité l'Europe de
l'indépendance l'Europe de la
coopération
elle contribue à donner une place
politique réelle au Parlement européen
dans la prise de décision elle est
récompensé en 1980 du prix Charlemagne
qui récompense des personnalités qui ont
de vrai pour la construction européenne
elle quitte le Parlement européen en
1993 et rejoint le gouvernement français
comme ministre des Affaires sociales et
de la santé et de la ville elle et par
la suite membres du Conseil
constitutionnel durant 9 ans au niveau
européen elle est de nouveau sollicité
en 1996 pour être membre de la
commission internationale pour les
Balkans son dernier engagement politique
pour l'Europe intervient lors de la
campagne pour la ratification par la
France du Traité constitutionnel
européen de 2005 elle soutient le oui au
référendum avec énergie Simone Veil a
également occupé la place de présidente
de la Shoah memories fondation et a été
membre du conseil d'administration de
Liffré en 2008 elle est élu à l'Académie
française
son travail pour l'Europe a été reconnu
en France et à l'étranger et on retient
d'aller une vision d'espoir et de
progrès pour l'Europe Simone Veil est
décédé en 2017 à l'âge de 89 ans est
entré au panthéon en 2018
je reçois aujourd'hui Laurence parents
eurodéputés membres du groupe EUROPE et
de la Commission de la culture et de
l'éducation Bonjour bonjour Alors lors
de son intervention annuel devant le
Parlement européen la président de la
Commission européenne sur cela van der
Leyen à affirmer sa volonté de faire de
2022 l'année européenne de la jeunesse à
la première question est-ce que c'est
uniquement pour témoigner du soutien à
la jeunesse qui a été durement impactés
pendant cette crise sanitaire où est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un réel changement pour
la jeunesse que va faire l'Europe pour
la jeunesse et pour les jeunes dans leur
quotidien
alors l'Europe fait déjà beaucoup pour
la jeunesse dans leur quotidien sur
cette annonce il y a deux choses alors
c'est vrai qu'elle a été nous-même
député qui assiste au discours sur
l'état de l'Union nous étions les
premiers surpris par cette annonce les
premiers heureux aussi parce que
reconnaître la jeunesse en 2022 après un
an et demi de pandémie avec
cette solidarité intergénérationnelle
qui a joué à plein c'était majeur
maintenant il faut savoir ce qu'on a
fait mais avant de répondre à ça je
dirais que
l'Europe c'est beaucoup et la chose
emblématique nous avons fait c'est le
plan de relance qui s'appelle next
generation you qui est vraiment issu du
Parlement européen des institutions et
qui vise à faire un emprunt d'avenir et
donc un emprunt pour les jeunes
générations donc voilà c'est le sens de
l'Europe c'est de bâtir et et de cette
politique avons mené et que moi je
revendique particulièrement elle est
tourné vers les jeunes maintenant la
difficulté c'est que les jeunes se
l'approprie donc on en est là et en SAS
cette année européenne de la jeunesse
peut avoir cette vertu maintenant il
faut en faire quelque chose alors la
stratégie de l'Union européenne en
faveur de la jeunesse ça repose sur
plusieurs instruments à vous en parliez
les activités d'apprentissage la
planification d'activité national
international futur le dialogue de
l'Union européenne en faveur de la
jeunesse la plateforme de la stratégie
de l'Union européenne en faveur de la
jeunesse des outils sont des qui donne
des données probantes le coordinateur
européen des activités relatives à la
jeunesse est le point de contact entre
la Commission européenne et une
référence visible pour pour les jeunes
est-ce que vous comprenez qu'une partie
de la population qui sache qui sait pas
vraiment ce qui se passe ici à
Strasbourg ou à Bruxelles notamment chez
les jeunes qui sait pas les décisions
qui sont prises vous parlez de que les
jeunes Pro prix ses décisions et ce plan
de relance ne comprennent pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a l'impression qu'on
dépense de l'argent pour rien ils ont
l'impression que l'argent qu'on dépense
dans l'Europe et ben pourquoi pas le
dépenser directement dans leur quotidien
l'impression que cet argent part et
qu'il leur vois jamais alors je sais
même pas si la réflexion va jusque-là de
se dire tiens l'Europe fait elle dépense
des choses qui vont je sais pas où je
crois qu'il y a et c'est le constat que
je fais en travaillant sur le nos
différentes politiques et notamment dans
le cadre de la conférence pour l'avenir
de l'Europe de se dire l'Europe fait
elle doit être mieux identifié mieux
connu et en effet je suis d'accord avec
vous pour un citoyen
parmi les plus jeunes générations se
dire tiens il y a un coordinateur
européens au sein de la commission c'est
moins. De rentrer pour faire en sorte
que les politiques européennes reflète
aux attentes c'est illisible donc Piron
partie de cette année européenne de la
jeunesse pour rendre les choses visibles
et pour s'appuyer sur ce qui existe déjà
Erasmus + 1 qui touche la directement
qui est connu sur les politiques qui
sont mises en place dans le cadre de
l'emploi sur toutes les politiques que
nous allons déployés sur la question du
climat puisque là on sait que c'est un
enjeu majeur et une préoccupation
majeure voilà et alors après et puis
après il y a d'autres préoccupations
parce que selon qu'on habite dans de
certaines zones de l'Europe on peut
avoir d'autres
voilà il y a un baromètre qui dit que
les jeunes de l'Est veulent plutôt la
réduction des inégalités la lutte contre
la corruption là où leurs cousins de
l'Ouest vol la lutte pour le climat donc
on a toutes ses priorités à défendre de
manière uni mais en effet faisant sorte
que cette année de la journée soit une
année pour communiquer tout ce qui est
fait est pour recueillir surtout il faut
un dialogue s'instaure un dialogue le
sentiment d'appartenance à l'Europe et à
l'Union c'est quelque chose de très très
important pour faire comprendre le rôle
des eurodéputés de la Commission de
l'Union est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce
qu'ils qu'est-ce que vous avez à dire à
ceux qui se reconnaissent pas en Europe
et bien
j'ai à dire que
pour l'instant je vais leur dire que
c'est à nous institution nous améliorer
je pense que c'est vraiment parce que je
vais pas les accabler je pense que c'est
à nous à nous améliorer ses à
l'éducation de faire plus pour que cette
dimension d'éducation citoyenne à la
citoyenneté européenne soit vraiment
dans le corpus en et quand on est
adhérent et quand on est États membres
de l'Union européenne pour moi on doit
délivrer d'informations sur ce que fait
l'Union européenne il en va de même sur
le combat qu'on mène pour les médias bon
une fois qu'on a cette information il
faut inciter à la participation
à la participation vous en parler il y a
quelques secondes la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'Europe elle a été lancé le
9 mai 2021 occasion pour tous les
citoyens des pays membres de l'Union
européenne de s'exprimer sur leur vision
personnel de l'Europe pourrait dessiner
une nouvelle trajectoire vous l'avez dit
vous l'assumer lune on n'est pas parfait
c'est donc l'occasion de penser les play
peut-être prendre une voix direction
tous les thèmes pas bien être abordé en
transition énergétique transition
numérique les frontières ou encore la
santé qu'est-ce que vous attendez de
cette grande consultation et bien
elle est à souligner elle y a salué
parce que en effet c'est vraiment la
première fois qu à cette échelle en à
cet espace de discussion en plus il y a
des initiatives qu'ils sont relié au
plan national puisque le secrétaire
d'État aux Affaires européennes a lancé
une grande consultation vers les jeunes
la France est à l'initiative
et la France et notre politique donc ça
tombe bien on est au cœur du sujet
il y a une il y a une plateforme
Internet qui existe où on peut encore
déposer ses contributions il y en a déjà
à 22500 mais on pourra aller plus loin
on va dire avant que
futur. Europa.
Il faut déjà avoir une idée de ce que
fait le tu pourrais faire mieux donc
c'est pour ça que se disent cette
plate-forme elle est déjà
souvent par des gens qui connaissent un
peu par des organisations de jeunesse
mais c'est très bien parce qu'ils ont le
rôle à jouer et puis ils font ce travail
de terrain d'aller chercher des jeunes
qui sont plus éloigné et puis
il y a aussi les panels citoyens qui
sont réunis ici même à Strasbourg et ça
c'est très bien parce que c'est des
tirage au sort de jeunes de tous les
horizons de des citoyens de tous les
horizons et dans ce panel qui était
dédié à la jeunesse il y avait justement
un tiers de
1625 ans donc c'est très représentatif
et ça touche pas des experts est-ce que
vous pensez que pour toucher plus
facilement la jeunesse notamment en
France on va parler de la France parce
que c'est un cas forcément qu'on connait
on connaît bien est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas en parler un peu plus à l'école la
France est à l'initiative de sa
consultation
comment
aider les jeunes à savoir ce que vous
disais qu'il fallait réfléchir pour
réfléchir il faut savoir ce qui se passe
peut-être en parler plus à l'école oui
en effet il est tout à fait
indispensable alors bon j'ai pas
l'éducation entre nous ça reste une
compétence nationale mais justement vous
voyez dans la le cas de la conférence on
pourrait se dire moi je suis pas opposé
à l'ouverture des traités à se dire à
quel moment on peut intégrer de
nouvelles compétences pour que si
l'éducation dois-je dire et elle doit
agir à on n'est pas on devient citoyen
en as besoin de s'approprier une culture
un savoir donc en effet l'éducation
formelle à tous on voit la joie et
informel aussi le rôle des associations
association de jeunesse des
collectivités locales ont un grand rôle
à jouer auprès des jeunes donc voilà la
question des compétences et puis
besoin d'informations et puis je le
redis de nos médias aussi qui ont plus à
dire sur ce qui se passe en Europe alors
vous disiez les priorités ne sont pas du
tout les mêmes en fonction des
territoires mais est-ce que la crise
sanitaire qui cette fois-ci là ça a été
dans toute l'Europe dans le monde entier
est-ce que la crise sanitaire à
redistribuer les cartes pour le futur de
l'Union européenne est-ce que finalement
la direction qui devait être prise au
départ va bien sûr qu'elle totalement tu
as écrit il y a pas sûr que pas mais je
crois qu'on accélère et c'est plutôt pas
mal parce que
dès le début de cette mandature
européenne le nouveau pacte vers donc la
question du climat a été central elle
pour la porter dans mon groupe politique
la Commission en a fait un marqueur très
fort on va l'accélérer on va l'accélérer
d'autant qu'on a les moyens qui ont été
mis en place supplémentaire vont être
beaucoup diriger sur ce sujet tout comme
sur la question du numérique or le
numérique on a vu pendant la pandémie
aussi combien c'était potentiellement un
facteur d'inégalité qu'il faut corriger
donc deuxième. Et troisième. L'Europe de
la santé puisque là aussi c'était pas
dans nos compétences et subitement
s'est mis à fabriquer à reproduire des
vaccins donc ça va toucher aussi
l'autonomie stratégique parce que ce
qu'il faut dire aux jeunes c'est que ils
sont
les vecteurs c'est eux qui vont prendre
notre avenir en main c'est eux qui vont
devoir se former à porter une excellente
qu'elle soit académique technique dans
tous les domaines pour que notre
continent reste au top du leadership
international merci beaucoup Laurence
parents d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
membres de la commission de la culture
et de l'éducation mort de Renaud Europe
et je rappelle que si vous souhaitez
participer à la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'Europe rendez-vous sur le site
internet futur. Europa.eu
voyage
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine
nous vous faisons découvrir le fish and
chips un plat typiquement British la
recette de Quentin du restaurant Poppys
à Rouen en Seine-Maritime
alors bonjour je m'appelle Quentin avec
mon associé Léonie on a fondé il a 4 ans
donc on pose la recette traditionnelle
de
tout simplement des migrants portugais
et espagnol qui ont fait la péninsule
Angleterre et on a porté beaucoup de
recettes à base de friture dont le fish
and chips
[Musique]
en Angleterre pour apprendre la recette
traditionnelle
[Musique]
en
allemand
et la farine convenant jusqu'à 20
texture onctueuse alors ensuite il faut
du poisson frais bien évidemment du
citron des pommes de terre ou pas les
frites et une pincée de sel au-dessus du
au-dessus du fish and chips et après les
puristes 0 qu'il faut prendre du
vinaigre de malt à qui le vinaigre
vinaigre particulier qui rajoute une
saveur vraiment au poisson et ensuite un
fish and chips c'est sa compagne une
sauce tartare une sauce tartare maison
bien sûr
il faut faire une mayonnaise maison
il faut des câpres cornichon
persil ciboulette et Estragon et la
sauce tartare excellente
un peu chaud avec tes friteuse
alors l'élément base bien sûr c'est de
la farine
et ensuite
de l'eau
[Musique]
alors je verse l'eau doucement
dans le bol
avec le batteur finalement on peut aussi
faire à la main
alors je vais tout doucement la farine
tu es vraiment la pâte est vraiment très
simple à faire c'est vraiment deux
éléments
de l'eau
pardon
le seul au pétillante et la farine
une fois que la
la pâte ou la bâtard comme
finalement
et Pépé ce n'est pas trop
ça veut dire que tu es prêt
[Applaudissements]
encore
davantage
tu es là
on est tous bon c'est la bonne la bonne
texture pas trop épaisse
mais suffisamment pour que la batteur
colle au poisson
je dispose la partie 6
je vérifie classeur friteuse est la
température à
180 degré de préférence
et là
le poisson et laisser
lancer de l'arrivage de ce matin
aujourd'hui ça va être du filet de merlu
du filet de cabillaud ou un autre fils
et ça fait le jaune ou encore plus d'eau
si on veut
en plus c'est une belle pièce
non pas le prêt défilé de 140 g
Voici
on va disposer un tout petit peu de sel
dessus
et c'est tout
des dessins de farine pour la pâte
au poisson
on va retourner un poisson pour qu'il
avait partout on tape un peu pour pas
que il y a un excès de farine et tout
simplement on va tremper le poisson dans
dans la dans la pâte
Voici on les fait couler légèrement on
peut verser tranquillement voilà quelque
chose
et voilà la magie opère
6 minutes pour faire cuire les frites en
même temps une fois que la panière
commence à être elle dort et des frites
également on va pouvoir sortir et
et la voici un fish and chips à
l'anglaise
prêt déguster
alors voilà le fichier et maintenant
vous allez m'accompagner il faut faire
la tartare
alors pour faire la tartare on a besoin
DE premièrement
on va les blanchir
bon robot
papa
blanche et on va pouvoir ajouter le jus
de citron
tu vas pouvoir ajouter
de l'huile
et voilà c'est parfait alors du coup je
vais couper un peu de persil
on peut le hacher grossièrement
on le met directement sur la mayonnaise
la ciboulette pareil
ah c'est tomber les échalotes
on va rajouter les cornichons
je couds grossièrement ce que j'ai la
machine qui va qui va mixer et faire des
morceaux un peu plus un les quatre je
vais directement dedans
ensuite je mets l'estragon le sel et
poivre
on va finir par
mélanger le tu as pas
on va pouvoir arrêter la machine
on va prendre la sauce tartare qui est
la sauce indispensable pour accompagner
le fish and fish comme
service
les superstitions en Europe avec Évelyne
Keller auteur du livre 301 superstition
petite encyclopédie des peurs et sagesse
populaire chez l'opportun on s'intéresse
cette semaine au sel le sel dans la
société paysanne d'avoir l'air
industrielle on en avait besoin parce
que ça permet de garder les aliments la
somme
donc tout le monde a eu du sel à la
maison mais en même temps depuis le
Moyen-âge ils ont attribué le sel au
diable au malin le baptême chrétien
autre choix ça n'est plus dans le
protocole lors du baptême on mettait une
pincée de sel sur la bouche d'un enfant
qui se mettait pour
éloigner le malin
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui merci aux
équipes techniques du Parlement européen
de Strasbourg vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en podcast audio et vidéo
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation et aussi sur TV 78
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine très
bonne soirée
[Musique]
zone Europe avec le soutien financier de
la région Île-de-France